[Music]
hello people
learning more about this program
because I want to be able to do this
better
[Music]
foreign
what's going on guys it's it's Lord
addict here you know uh me and King are
here you know we we we we killing it man
we we doing this on Valentine's Day you
know I almost lost my relationship over
this no I'm joking I'm joking that's why
I'm all dressed up you know uh I got uh
I'm leaving right after the show to to
go out uh but you know first off wanna
well welcome to the stream awful he said
it's the first time he's been here King
first time he's been on r r with the
Lords Mr Grim bones awful dream bones
greetings uh and as Maddie says
salutations salutations yeah I always
think it's funny when he says that so
what's going on you guys r with the
Lords we talk about
entertainment movies TV we talk about
anything pretty much on the big screen
the small screen the side screen
anything you want to think of uh we talk
about you know we do got a pretty good
show for you guys today uh we're going
to go over the Last of Us episode five
breakdown obviously you know that's one
of the hottest things out there that we
cannot not talk about that we're gonna
also talk about a movie that I found
it's got a little gym it's called The
Fall which is funny I found it through
Tick Tock we'll get in that later on and
then we're going to talk about the flash
Trail I know a lot of people want to
hear our opinions on it actually have a
patreon dedicated to flash patreon
question and then obviously we got you
know the the up to dates you know uh I
know King's watching you and King's
still watching Attack on Titan uh so
we'll briefly go over Attack on Titan
because we are doing live reactions so
if you want to see the majority of you
know that you will go over there for
that but you will talk about that so
King
you
I don't know where I left oh I left off
the way he got the girl and he uh was a
uh
a two a two-pump trump
a one second man
um
it didn't look good for the kid you know
he was going through uh normal uh
anxieties you know as a man and he's
checking her phone because remember he
still has her old phone and it's still
connecting he's still getting the text
messages so remember this is season one
guys and I'm getting acclimated to um
what's going on with Joe
so uh Joe is uh seeing it you know she's
still down with it that but she has a
deep dark secret and you know she's uh
he thought she was hooking up with
somebody for the weekend you know the
guy send the 500 to go get an outfit and
it did look like some sugar daddy thing
going on there yo it looked kind of
crazy when oh boy hopped out the car
I was like wow so why didn't she just
sleep with the teacher I'm like the
teacher looked like a better option than
this old foggy that hopped out the whip
I'm like oh buddy what's going on here
and then he had on this pirate suit I'm
like I don't know what Kink stuff they
into I said I don't know what attic has
me watching but um come to find out that
was her father who she claimed was dead
but he wasn't dead but he was dead to
her because he left their family her
family her mom's and herself and found a
new family
um and uh you know it was really through
his journey to becoming sober uh he
found this uh evangelist that was at the
church and she helped guide him or felt
that she helped guided him on his way to
becoming sober so you know the daughter
always felt that he felt beholden to her
helping him and that's the resentment
that she has for them and then you know
the family don't like her because it's
tied to the Past
so it's a big uh cluster Buck if you
want to use those words you know in in a
situation
but Joe was there Joe went and got the
room right next to where she was staying
and you know she sees him in the crowd
and Joe got his his stalker game A plus
oh my God chef's kiss for his stalker
game his stalker game is probably the
best stalker game I don't want no one to
stalk me the way Joe stalk Joe stalked
the best
he's very detailed like he knows what to
look for he knows when he's being looked
at he knows when to not linger too long
like he is literally the definition of
like a private detective that you would
never want on you
packs he has he gets all the info
even started jogging
to stay up with peaches or Peach you
know um and
you know every now that he finds out
that that's how pops and they had this
whole uh big thing
and you know she kind of Screams on Joe
because Joe confronts her with the the
Royal truth of the matter with her pops
and how she was behaving you know she
kind of yelled them out and you know
kind of bit his head off and you know
Joe
he's a weird uh fellow because he's not
an aggressive person
you know um
it's just he's I'm getting to know him
so his personality right now seems
non-confrontational he doesn't want to
do things unless forced to do things or
he feels like he's back in the corner or
something do you see what I was talking
about on you know how they portray him
and they do a good job we're starting to
make you like low-key feel bad that
you're like low-key rooting for him like
yeah well I'm sympathetic to Joe in some
instances like I was definitely
sympathetic to Joe when he's a two-pump
jump
um nobody wants that's that type of
action but I mean you know your big
homie supposed to tell you you're
supposed to pre-game before you even sit
down and have the Super Bowl but you
know he didn't know that he he went in
you know a little drying situations got
crazy but um now you know they're back
and they're getting into the swing of
things and he happens to have a
Redemption Song with a and he does his
thing and you know now they're like a
couple
and she's presenting him to her friends
and Joe was playing the game on how to
pit friends against each other because
you know Peach is out for blood when it
comes to anything that Guinevere
um likes
and she's trying to separate him from
her
and she's uh at peaches is that is and
peaches also make sure that she drives
enough wedge in between the other
friends that she becomes a so isolated
friend that she can go to and depend on
and that's that's like a weird dynamic
and come to find out that this girl has
been stalking a Guinevere for a long
time because she's in love with this
girl and you know it took who
sneak Snoopy Joe to to find out you know
all the information and all the tea well
I got to the park this is where I ended
it off right I got to this part
Joe's jogging he's running behind and he
got his win now Joe can actually keep up
with this Broad and she's jogging she's
jogging and he's running behind her and
he bashes her in the head with a brick
she falls out he thinks she's dead he
runs off real hard real fast and he gets
back to his uh apartment where the
little boy has poisoned his uh his his
mother's boyfriend
and Joel you know turns him over gets
them to you know cough up the pills and
then God turns over and beats the crap
out of jail and Joe's Landing he didn't
fight back Joel like I said he's
non-confrontational you know what the
best thing about that show is like hit
his navigation him talking to you when
everything's going on like he'll sit
there and he'll start to get beat up by
this like he'll he'll like make a
smart-ass comment on what he's doing in
his head and you can hear it because
he's navigating the show like yeah and
it's so crazy his narration is nuts
because he says while he's getting beat
up this is karma for the bad thing that
I've done today and I deserve this and
it's like self-punishment is what he's
putting himself through and he's laying
there bloody and then uh one of her
calls
and he picks up and he's like hello and
she's like yeah Peach has been attacked
in the park and we're at the hospital
and he's like what she's alive
and that's where it cuts and I'm I'm on
to that so yeah you have me thoroughly
invested inside of you Paul's uh that's
[Laughter]
but um yeah and you wanted me to watch
fall so you know full full disclosure
guys
we do let's talk a little bit about the
uh the the elephant in the room man you
know what that is
uh for those of you that don't know we
do have a a patreon and I know some of
you wanted King to to react to the
attack on Titan stuff so he did he
reacted to the female Titan versus Levi
uh this is live like straight up like
live but you can watch this in real time
it's on our patreon uh you know it's in
the description you can look for the
patreon and give a brief analysis on
Levi's strength now that you've seen him
like fight a little bit on his Peak
mmm
I have conflicting thoughts about this
man
I despise him and I despise him to his
core
because I don't like him I don't
I don't like him at all
but I cannot deny the man's skill
his skill
oh my God he doesn't move
when I think this Titan has him dead to
rights
and he goes up this Titan's arm straight
to the eyes like this Titan couldn't
react the Titan never seen this move
ever neither has anybody in in the
survey team to be honest with you and
the way that he cuts down this Titan is
with
Dr Precision like a scalpel going
through flesh
it's nuts it's nuts to see but I still
think he's a Despicable
deplorable human being so exciting tell
the chat why you think he's despicable
because he doesn't share his moves if he
would have shared his moves with his
team he okay
anybody anytime somebody wants full
disclosure on what somebody else is
doing like hey man you know I want you
to tell me everything that you're doing
I want to know everything about you I
want you to be full transparent with me
and this is where he is a terrible
person because he doesn't give exactly
what he's looking for from others
so
I will say I'm not going to ruin
anything I will say there's a reason he
can't teach his skills I believe you
yeah there's actually only one other
person in the whole show that can that
can be just as good as him well
he is nice as hell still deployed
so that's pretty much all when it comes
to that you know I think that uh you
guys will enjoy those live reactions uh
his female one came out today uh you
know I was gonna launch it tomorrow but
I was like you know what since it's r r
let's do it today and that way you guys
can uh go in there enjoy that for the
people that's uh sub to the seven dollar
tier on the patreon uh like I said it's
in the description below so let's let's
talk about fall so
fall pretty much you know fall is a
movie of two
two friends two women uh they are their
extremeness you know they love to climb
the highest mountains uh you know Mount
Everest stuff like that and at the end
of the show they had a tragedy and so
that pretty much one of them they're
both Adrenaline Junkies but one took it
way worse than the other you know what
I'm saying and that's a it's been a lot
it's been like a couple months since
I've seen it both of them may have not
been there it may have just been one uh
but that one was pretty much where they
couldn't they could no longer do that
adrenaline stuff they were scared uh
because they they had a tragedy that
happened and someone passed away from
the tragedy uh so this one's pretty much
like the uh the the one that is still
doing the stuff trying to get her best
friend to you know go ahead and jump
into that again you know you you know
it's been it's been like six months to a
year you know I I understand you got
trauma we we got to work through this
trauma because you keep in mind even
though that she's traumatized like she
still misses it she just can't bring
herself to do it anymore so she doesn't
have the nerve anymore yeah so pretty
much what it's about is it for her to
fight
those that trauma they climb a giant
cell phone tower that's rusted
and they get stuck at the top
and this isn't like this isn't one of
those things where they can
this is like
uh easily a couple hundred foot in the
air like there's no way they can live
falling off this thing uh and then the
ladder that connects the bottom half to
the top
breaks when they're climbing down so
they're stuck up there uh no cell phone
reception nothing they try whatever they
can to get like a message to the bottom
to show they're there but it's what I
like about the show is you know ever
since we started on r r I've been giving
a lot more like b-rated movies a chance
yeah and what I like about this is
they do a good pacing you know you find
out uh they have a lot of drama between
them that you know they they the the one
that was traumatized kind of new but she
never confronted you know what I'm
saying and it's like you know when
they're up at this top they happen to
fight through this trauma fight through
hunger fight through uh being thirst
dehydrated and they're they're trying to
keep in mind it's the middle of the
desert so no one's coming
wow
um the other one jump on the top of the
other one to jump off so she can no no
uh I won't I won't ruin it but you know
I recommend everyone go try it you know
it's on Stars right now you can go play
it and I think that this is definitely a
good movie to watch you know I would
give it a like a three star four-star
around that area probably three full
popcorn yeah three popcorn I do feel
like it's it's worth the watch like I
feel like there's very few movies I'll
watch twice usually I'll give anything
once but there's very few movies I
watched more than once well more than
likely I'm gonna get a chance to check
that out this week like I said I lost
the whole day on Sunday uh when I was uh
burning the candle at both ends I don't
ever be able to make it to the podcast
if you look at the video I said uh that
the picture that's in the podcast
um that's ridiculous that's where they
are that's how much room they have up
there
why you don't go with a parachute that's
that's the or glider you know we'll see
they're Adrenaline Junkies they they
believe in taking as less stuff up there
as possible and they're like survival
junkies too like they don't believe they
did take stuff up there but there is a
reason why they don't have as much stuff
as they normally would something does
happen uh so you know it it's crazy man
they they they try uh to to get down
multiple different ways like multiple
different ways uh so and then you know
I'll say there's some twists in the
movie man like I said there's drama
between them that's brought up at the
top of this thing you can see the amount
of space that they have in this on this
thing it is nothing like nothing and I I
think I think the
instead of space for two you know yeah
there's definitely you could probably
fit three or four people up there very
uncomfortably
um me personally I'm going up there with
a wingsuit okay I'm just jumping off put
my wingsuit and bye
yeah so yeah I think I think you guys
will like it like I said it's on Stars
you can buy it on Prime uh on Amazon
Prime for like 20 bucks or rent it for
like five
oh you're not 100 off you're not 100 off
like they got that adrenaline junkie
stuff uh you know and it's not a video
game so they're they're they're honed by
reality like they they're not going to
get off of this without some crazy stuff
happening and the the hard part is
they're trying to get
help but it's hard because they're so
high up
that there's no cell phone service there
that's ridiculous because this is Mr
Joanna dark met him at the New York
video games Awards uh lovely individual
to meet in person uh very personable I
mean it's so great to actually get out
and meet you know uh people and you know
have great conversations and share a
moment and experience uh you can go
check his timeline I suggest everybody
goes to his Twitter page is Mr Joy in
the dark and um you know follow him
um and check out his stuff man he's a
cool dude and you know I really respect
that he showed up and shout out to
Sinister and everybody that's here got
32 people watching thank you for tuning
in especially on Valentine's Day this
will be a very uh quick hour uh because
attic is in uh sexy time at it close
and me personally I am ready for the
show
so all right I think a lot of people are
here for this uh you know it was crazy
we got two big topics this next topic is
Flash oh God yes so we are talking about
the flash now I do got a patreon
question related to The Flash so I was
going to save it for this particular
part
we've got a uh a patreon question from
dip down games and Anime what are your
feelings towards the Flash trailer does
gun have them on the right track people
are hyped about Michael Keane being back
keep up those anime reactions they are
fire fire Emoji I had a I had to say all
three fire emojis so uh you know I did
react to this so you on the uh on the r
r Channel you could see my law uh my raw
reaction to this trailer I was so
oblivious to like the older Batman's the
the uh George Clooney's the or at least
Batman I can remember okay so I didn't
know there was people before him
and apparently this dude is the 80s
Batman oh yeah that's that's the first
uh big screen Batman
um Michael Keaton
gave Batman that cool you know because
you know before then you know from the
TV show Adam West uh did uh a car uh
a corny type of Batman you know uh Adam
West Batman was tongue-in-cheek fun
something that can be shown on
television but this Batman
uh Tim Burton's Michael Keaton's Batman
is uh something fantastic and uh him and
Jack Nicholson set the pace for what um
this superhero movie should be like you
know so he's very iconic in this role
yeah um question about this because I
don't know a whole lot first off let's
go ahead and take care of this patreon
question do you think that uh gun has
them on the right track I don't think
this particular film has anything to do
with gun this film was already almost
done before he switched Rose whoa I mean
I think he might have switched certain
things in it but I think the overall
perspective of the movie hasn't been
changed no
um the script and stuff was already done
he went in to do a lot of reshoots and
stuff like that
um but at the same time
they still kept the film they got rid of
Batwoman
you know oh Batgirl whatever they was
going to call it they got rid of no it
was Batgirl
they got rid of the Batgirl film because
they said it was unwatchable it was an
unmitigated mess of a film and they just
ate the 20 million or whatever million
that they put into the film
um
so the flash is this movie is very
necessary for his starting off the DC EU
without this film he can't do it he it
it doesn't happen so this film has to
happen in order to set everything right
so so that's why this film had to come
out you know even though you know Ezra
Miller uh was charged with the stuff
that he was charged to and he pled
guilty for whatever he pled guilty for
and uh he has to do whatever he has to
do uh with that I believe that uh you
know Warner Brothers is going to walk
away from Ezra Miller after this film
but um the only person I think pardon me
feels like they're not going to I don't
know yeah they pretty much said he's
done
pretty much that he stopped I wonder
what they're gonna do at the end to like
show another flash to like kill him
they're gonna kill him yeah kill him
because all right so okay in the comic
books imagine what it would be like to
be Ezra Miller and you you screw up to
that degree and you you're like okay
maybe I'm fine maybe I'm fine and then
the director calls you yeah we need you
to come and uh fill some shoots about
you dying like well the thing about it
is Barry Allen always dies
he's he's never The Flash
Wally West takes that role Wally West is
uh the Young Flash so Barry Allen is
always supposed to die he dies in in
crisis between infinite herbs and if
you're doing Flashpoint you know um the
flash point is going to uh precipitate
his death
because he's going to probably be racing
Against Time uh to set back everything
that he uh broke and in doing so he's
going to meet himself and when he meets
himself and I'm talking about when he
meets himself inside the speed force
when he meets himself inside the speed
force he's going to have to outrun death
when he has to outrun death he's going
well the Grim Reaper the I did see that
in the in the Flash TV show yeah because
I remember Tyler introducing me of that
show and uh there was like like a flash
that was like like decayed and stuff
like he was messed up is that like the
original flash that was great speed
force and he goes and he eliminates
anomalies in the timeline from
speedsters that has broken the law in
the time uh space continues is there any
particular reason he has like the
Flash's outfit and stuff on
at some point in time the flash becomes
that okay that's why
I see that I see that
um you know I think when it comes to
this
I honestly do think that you know gun is
going to use this movie to like kind of
restart the whole thing all of it yeah
uh because if you see they they brought
back uh you know General Zod which
really surprised me I didn't expect that
uh I I'm curious how they do that you're
gonna be crazy if he lives well
remember
okay I'm gonna give you the the quick
synopsis remember he went to a different
timeline and he's been searching
timelines to find the time and this is
Barry Allen this is The Flash this is
Ezra Miller he's been searching
different timelines to find the timeline
that his mother is still alive and then
he finds the timeline that his mother's
still alive in but it happens to be the
timeline that Michael Keaton's Batman
okay so that's making a little bit more
sense right because if you notice
there's two Batmans in that trailer the
Ben Affleck Batman and the Michael
Keaton Batman right and he's talking to
Ben Affleck in the beginning and he's
telling Ben Affleck this is what I can
do I can do this
and and you know and Ben Affleck is like
trying to give him reason like bro
you're going to break something you're
going to do something and he does break
it and he does he gets stuck into that
that time and
he sees his mother but there's
repercussions to it because when doing
so he has eliminated all meta-humans
right so there's no metahumans that can
stop Zod when Zod comes in and Zod comes
down when God comes down Zod wants to
take over the planet he still wants to
terraform this planet there's no
Superman to stop that so I wonder where
Superman is
he doesn't exist
he was killed
how is he killed though like he was
killed in the planet he was killed and
so instead of but you see Supergirl in
it so right Cara gets out
uh uh what you call Cal doesn't never
leave
so Kara gets off the planet because Cara
all right so in our original timeline
Cara and Cal are both shipped out but
huzz has a malfunction and hus get uh
her ship gets stuck in space a little
bit longer than uh Cal is but so when
cal
um
is on Earth he's on Earth for a longer
period of time so he's absorbed more of
the
sun rays so he's a little bit stronger
than when she lands right and then when
she lands he's older than she is if that
makes any sense even though when they
left she was older than him
because he he aged quicker with the sun
no it was just a time difference between
her getting from the planet she was
still in Christ
he was living his life or whatever it
took her longer to get to the planet and
she was her whole body was frozen so
right so all right so she gets here but
okay so now I don't know how they're
gonna tell this story but she's here he
isn't and James Gunn
says that she's going to be the you know
the Supergirl woman I mean uh the the
Supergirl movie is going to be his
jumping off point for like metahumans
and stuff like that if they can have the
Continuum in that world I thought the
trailer showed too much because I didn't
want to see Supergirl and anytime a
movie shows so much in a trailer yeah it
kind of um they show Batman Flash the
The Flash doppelganger they definitely
show too much like they just showed a
doppelganger okay so what you saw was
remember there's two Ezra Miller's right
so when he catches the power of the
flash he's trying to reenact the thing
that gave him his power
he probably sparked the other Flash the
other Ezra Miller into having the speed
force so here so our Ezra Miller already
has the speed force he's making sure
that that uh as you remember that Barry
Allen catches the speed force oh yeah
probably different flashes and probably
both you need both of them to to win
that fight
which is crazy because if you think I
don't know who's I don't think General
Zod is the main antagonist that's the
thing well at least they didn't tell us
that if he's not like
I agree with you I actually think they
should have been vague on Batman being
in it well we knew already um that it
was two Batmans I knew I really I knew a
long time ago Michael Keaton was there
but then they went back and said they
wrote Michael Key now but then uh come
to find out that James Gunn has kept uh
Michael Keaton's Batman there
because they didn't want to confuse the
uh the audience but Ben Affleck is not
coming back as Batman
that's done
so I don't know where they go with this
is it is is Patterson's Batman Batman
Patterson's Batman is in an else World
type of Batman so what do they do for
you take the retcon his Batman into the
DC Universe I don't think so I don't
think Patterson even wants to be in you
know uh Batman movies for 20 years you
know I don't think so
yeah I I guess to me when it comes to
this you know I actually did this this
particular movie just jumped up in my
height like way high like originally oh
yeah I'll probably watch it because I
have to do r r with it but what could be
something I'm gonna be like yo King
we're gonna watch it the Friday it comes
out but now I'm just like okay you know
I think I might I'm more excited for
this than maybe even Guardians of the
Galaxy now like oh you saw that one too
yeah that was pretty good talk about
that one too
I react to that one too are we finished
with this uh because you know I give
them my synapses on it um did you give
your synopsis on it like you said your
trailer got your excitement super high
yeah yeah I think it's I think it's
gonna be a good movie I think people are
going to really enjoy this and
hopefully they leave you wanting more
after this movie you know you'll be
crazy to kill Michael Keaton's Batman
you know what they got a cartoon and I'm
gonna check and see if it's on HBO Max
and I want you to read I want you to
watch the cartoon forget the book
um I want you to watch the cartoon
because I'm pretty sure oh it was pretty
it was done really really well and you
might really like that you might really
like tell me if it's on HBO max if not
uh what's that service that people put
like digital movies into
I don't know we can't say it yeah no no
like you literally put your digital
codes into it like that you get from
buying movies like video I know what
you're talking about yeah well Tyler's
got like a bunch in there and he he's
got like a giant movie collection so HBO
doesn't have it he probably has it I can
watch it on that dude I'm pretty sure he
has it yeah it's ridiculous how many
movies that dude has all right Guardians
of the Galaxy all right so hold up hold
up hold up get that up pause the next
thing we're going to talk about is
Guardians of the Galaxy that trailer you
know I actually I saw that and what I
like what I saw is the fact that they're
they're introducing people I've never
seen
who was the dude that was fighting I
can't remember that huh the black guy
no it was it was the white Adam Warlock
Adam Warlock the gold dude yeah the gold
dude Adam Warlock I have no clue who he
is so give me uh a play about play
hugely important to the MCU now you
would have thought that you know when
they did Infinity Gauntlet him and
Thanos he is like the arch nemesis to
Thanos he
first name is him
and he was created
and the being that they have the high
evolutionary in the trailer which is the
black guy and he has his skin pulled
across his face if if you saw the
trailer it's like
how they how they doing the high
evolutionary is though because they're
giving you the story of Rocket Raccoon
and he wants to go back to his Homeworld
because he wants to stop him and he what
he does is he takes animals and what
they say is they modify him but what he
says is he he hates what he sees so he
tries to change it and that's Rocket's
viewpoint on him so you see Rocket's
girlfriend there because he goes back
and uh she's um
she's a sea otter and she has a robotic
arm and you know you see that you're
going to see a lot of man beasts uh that
he makes the high evolutionary does but
the high Evolution a high evolutionary
is supposed to take Adam Warlock and
turn him into Adam Warlock turn them
from him
into Adam Warlock where he's a sentient
being so that that gem that he has on
his head so it's supposed to be a Soul
Fist I don't think it was that dude I
remember thanos's brother is an eternal
correct that's not this dude what Thanos
no that's not Star Fox okay
because I don't I don't know these at
like these random characters I just I
just don't no no it's it's fine this is
perfect because you're going to get
introduced to a whole bunch of different
characters and this is what I like about
James Gunn James Gunn takes a lot of
unknown characters and he makes you know
him and make you fall in love with them
but also takes well-known characters
like uh The Collector and and the Grand
Master and and characters like that and
have you understand more about them so
you're going to learn more about animal
warlock what I liked in the trailer and
they showed Peter Quill and
um what was uh Thanos uh daughter of the
robot one she was holding nebula was
holding him and his body was draped in
her arms I think that is a fake out I
think it's uh it's not a real scene and
I think they have somebody else that
they're carrying there and it could be
Drax I think it could be Drax or it
could be uh it might be drags
now let's talk about the elephant in the
room the real elephant in the room is
why is Dave Bautista looking like he
eating cheeseburgers uh
at a at a rate that is going out of
style I mean I'm not isn't he done with
his contract hasn't he pretty much been
very vocal that he's done
because it's it's highly rumored oh uh
Tyler says he does have it on there so
I'll be able to watch it next week
um what's up I'm curious to see if
someone really does die do you think
someone's gonna die in this movie yes do
you think most people are gonna die in
this movie we got 56 people we only got
31 likes please let's fix that up oh
hold on Boston raid what's going on with
the five dollar Super Chat Adam is
incredibly strong and very important to
the MCU both Guardians and Flash look
fantastic that is true
um he is he is hugely important to
anything that's space worthy so when you
get the Silver Surfer and you get
Galactus coming in and and all that
stuff he's definitely necessary to start
furthering those uh conversations
because when you do get a chance to
break the Multiverse and we're going to
get that in Ant-Man uh this week and and
uh Mr uh attic and I will be talking
about that next week yeah so most likely
because what I want to do with the
spoiler cast is unless there's something
seriously going down I want to dedicate
that whole show to that spoiler cast you
know what I'm saying I got you and you
don't have a thumbnail has three
different pictures just one I want that
to be no I want that to be three
different pictures of that movie it's
the same movie okay I'm down with you
um yeah so I think we're going to see
the rebirth for Thanos
I think this is where Adam Warlock plays
a huge part so
Guardians Of The Galaxy sets up Adam
Warlock and his uh Gathering has
strength and if anybody played the video
game which is a great video game I
suggest y'all do so so you can get more
versed in Adam Warlock
and I never even booted at all you
definitely should it's a damn good game
but then also
King is going to have a Face-Off with
Thanos at some point in time in this
movie
in this movie I believe so you think
Thanos is going to be in this movie in
some way shape or form they're going to
go into the timeline they're going into
the Multiverse so
uh there's multiple timelines and
yes I believe so I mean that's my
prediction for it that's the way that
you bring Thanos back and you have to
pit down those verses out of Warlock and
if Adam Warlock happens to have a soul
gem on his head then he's going to want
to get that soul gem off of Adam's
warlock's heads that'd be interesting do
you think they bring Thanos back in the
Ant-Man movie yes and you think that
will carry yeah I think yeah I think
they bring him back in in the Ant-Man
movie and uh
and Guardians of the Galaxy
I don't think they touch on it I think
it's something a little bit down the
line that you're probably getting King
Wars or something do you do you think
that
they'll bring him back in a big way of
the Ant-Man or it'll be like an aft like
an after credit scene
now I think it's going to be a main
scene in the movie oh man see it's gonna
be interesting I think Friday is when
the movie comes out
yeah so uh what next week will be a
spoiler cast on Ant-Man uh gonna be
interesting I'm very curious to see on
that so you know people in the chat go
watch it this weekend man if you want to
if you want to be there live when we
talk about it man you know go watch it
this weekend we're going to get ready
you know what I like about what I see on
Guardians of the Galaxy is just I like
that they never lost the tone of
Guardians of the Galaxy yep it feels
exactly how it felt from the first one
you know some could be good some could
be bad I know some people like Evolution
I don't think there's not evolution in
this but the tone never changes you
could still evolve characters without
evolving with the tone of this movie was
always about I mean like Thor how Thor
changed from exactly yeah I don't like
that like Thor kind of started as a dark
movie and then they just got lighter and
lighter and lighter and now he's like
like it's so bad that the main character
of Thor uh hymns uh what's his name is
like hey we want to play Thor anymore
unless he has more creative control over
Thor well yeah because he didn't like
the backlash that he got over the last
movie but that's Tyson watiti and he
didn't have anything to do with the
other two uh films that was in there I
think the Dark World was the one that I
I felt was deplorable and then I like uh
you know Tyson with TD's take on it
um Thor Ragnarok and been the last one
Ragnarok was the best one to me yeah
love and thunder I think he leaned too
heavily into it but James Gunn for the
Guardians of the Galaxy I mean he did
all three of them so
something happened to King
hold up
can you hear me yeah I can hear you I
have no clue what happened there okay
continue and and you know uh you know uh
James Gunn actually did all three of
them so he he keeps that continuity
between the characters there so yeah I
think I think the coolest thing about
this is like just the character
development you know I like in the
commercial uh in the in the trailer
they're sitting there in like like you
know um Star-Lord was talking to uh uh
uh Camilla what is her name oh which one
you said the green one oh you're talking
about uh
um oh Jesus uh uh now now I'm blanking
one's nebula I know that that's the
sister kamora Gamora yeah yeah so
they're talking to gramora and she's
like saying stuff that they don't get a
lot like why are they attract live with
like the dead her attracted to her and
they're saying stuff and she's like uh
saying the reasons and then he's like
yeah that she's like it's like you
should be attracted to her talk look at
the nebula and nebula's like like she
pauses for a second then it's like oh
God she's kind of right like yeah
Star-Lord Starlight stop looking at me
like that
yo um first I want to say thank you
Killian Brown welcome to Lord Browns
thank you my brother I do appreciate it
we appreciate everything
um we have 63 people watching again wipe
your feet hit that like button share it
out to a friend
it's on Valentine's Day we got we got
sexy time addict come on man is that not
uh worth a couple of likes sexy time
addict come on man
yeah so all right um one thing I liked
about this is group Groot was huge had
guns had multiple hands like group came
to this
for smoke
he's a he's a young a young adult now
yeah it's just crazy that
we got like the old Grid at the
beginning remember and then we got like
the T like the little kid group then we
get the teenager group now we're getting
the young adult group and he's buffed
dude he's like he's been in the gym for
like eight years
yo he's crazy I like
there's a scene in the trailer where you
have uh Star-Lord down on one knee and
Groot falls on top of him and you think
group crushes him but actually what the
group does is when he when he falls on
top of him he like forms an exoskeleton
and he takes the guns that's on uh
Star-Lord that Star-Lord has and he has
his guns and they go back to back and
they turn it around and they're shooting
beautiful stuff it's gonna be good man I
I have a lot of Hope for this this is a
crazy year of movies it's just insane
like every month there's stuff to watch
and you know hopefully we get sponsored
by Paramount and um
yeah yeah uh you know Paramount AMC you
know pull that truck up
holla at your boys all right so you know
that that's pretty much all I got on
yeah Guardians of the Galaxy I think
that people are really gonna like that
movie
yeah me too I'm I'm gonna love it oh I
hope I do I hope I'm right with the bait
and switch of the trailer
um to be honest with you and I hope I'm
wrong on the flash I really do I hope
they didn't show Too Much the last time
I seen that was Batman versus Superman
and they had dude they showed doomsday
and they show Wonder Woman and they kind
of let the cat out the back way too
early so
hope that doesn't happen again
all right so
King we gotta talk about it Last of Us
episode five you know I I think that
this is definitely one of the only times
you're gonna see me like kind of talk
positive about the shows
I I I I I still
and not filling the overall perception
of the show but what I will say about
this particular episode is it was it was
starting a little bit to you know clean
itself up a little bit you know
obviously I don't think that the damage
has been done for me you know but I do
think this is one of those things where
this is enough where I could say okay we
could start to Savage a little bit you
know we can we could start to have like
the end of the show beer we got three
episodes left you know uh there was a
good aspect to everything that went on
in the show you know we saw stuff that I
believe should have been in the show
already but I digress I'm not gonna
really push back too much because I do
think they showed the bloater in a very
good way uh you know actually I got a
picture of the bloater right there
he's huge he's disgusting and that's
exactly how I expected the bloater to
show up right uh you know especially how
he looks so first thing I want to talk
about is you know the overall I don't
want to go into you know the drama of
the town I don't want to really go into
what happened in the show yeah I just
want to get your overall perspective of
episode five of The Last of Us okay so
um when I talked to you earlier today uh
my wife never saw the last of us and I'm
playing the remastered one on my
PlayStation 5 and I'm probably going to
buy The Last of Us Part One
they got it for 39 bucks and
um
I might do that I might you know make it
an executive call to do that because I'm
playing the remastered version and ah
buddy doesn't doesn't age too well
so it looks clean but you know she's
she's seeing it and she's seeing a
little bit of the differences
this episode
it's it's kind of went back to how one
and two was
how the tone of one and two felt
it felt like three and four was uh like
four I didn't really like too much but
um
one and two was really good to me and
three was its own little thing that had
a lot of controversy around it I think
this episode five is giving you a nice
tone in trying to get back and then I
did see familiar Parts uh from the game
uh to the the show
and it kind of played very well because
I think those scenes needed to play out
how it played out and it did a good job
in doing so I saw a lot of uh violence I
saw the humans I saw the clickers I saw
the infected I saw the town with the
sniper that was at the high point that
kept them there
um they had to move from car to car so
these things was all Last of Us failing
the atmosphere felt like a
post-apocalyptic world when it was down
in the tunnels I felt very
claustrophobic so it was so many things
that was done uh in the storytelling not
even talking about uh the interaction
between the characters I'm just talking
about seeing the scene that uh it felt
like how the last of us is supposed to
fail you felt kind of hopeless in a lot
of parts in this uh the film and I
noticed it because I was uh watching my
wife and she was like shaking to be
honest with you because there were
certain scenes that she was grabbing my
shoulder and asking me is he gonna die
is he going to die and I'm like I'm not
answering your questions just excuse me
let it play out so yeah it was really
good stuff
all right so all right
first off let's brush up a little bit on
uh the bloater uh you know we'll talk
about the city drama too real quick I
actually felt like the city drama was a
little bit better than they did in the
game right but I do feel like they
should have uh you know expanded it more
you know I I personally feel like the
biggest issue of this of this show is
the amount of episodes that they were
worth investing into I feel like you
know eight they would have gave two more
episodes a good 10 episode season like
most people do these days I feel like
you could have gave a whole episode to
navigating the political disaster that
was known as this town you know what I'm
saying it's eight episodes
that's where the discrepancy came from
I'm thinking eight seasons it's eight
episodes
sound like a total idiot now okay yeah
so I personally felt like they should
have expanded more on this you know uh
one thing I want to say is the uh the
the woman that is running the town yeah
I don't feel like no one would ever back
her in any way shape or form like I
don't feel like she gives any qualities
whatsoever any characteristics that you
would believe in to run to to you know
successfully be a leader to you you know
I think she's uh extremely emotional she
doesn't really you know take this
episode nine oh okay she doesn't really
take the the group's opinion on anything
she doesn't think the group's needs for
anything you know when she shot the
doctor there was no like are we gonna
need this doctor that was I'm emotional
so I'm gonna kill the doctor and to me
you look at good leaders and TV like one
thing I one person I can think of right
now is Rick from The Walking Dead you
know he never would have made a move
like that even if he did not like like
that person he would have put the the
needs of the group over the needs of
himself and to me it didn't I didn't
understand why these people backed her
so much because she didn't put anything
into to to be honest with you this dude
right here he felt to me he had more
leadership Tendencies than she did Adam
I'm gonna get I'm giving you the
pushback on it
um the pushback on it is she told you
how her brother
uh I believe his brother her brother
name was Michael uh
how he was a great leader
even Henry said how much of a great
leader he was how much of a noble man he
was how how you would want to follow him
to the ends of the Earth how he's
talking about a person he ratted out and
um
how much everybody looked up to him but
that guy we have on screen right now uh
we're gonna say we're gonna call him uh
you know Hitman number one uh General
number one
yeah he didn't really add a whole lot to
the show no he really didn't but he had
to receive his dilemma I felt was more
like if I was gonna follow someone in a
scenario like that I would follow
someone like that that feels like they
have their stuff together and they got a
mindset on what's better for everyone
like I honestly do feel like he had the
intentions of the whole group over
himself and I just didn't feel that way
about the chick to me I don't see how
she can Captivate and Charisma and be
charismatic enough to get them people to
follow her so the thing with him is he's
following her because she formed real
change the other dude wasn't about
action and remember they said 20 years
uh fedra occupied this City Kansas City
so for 20 years fedra occupied the the
city and was beating raping and killing
people and Michael was in charge
Michael got sold out
and she got in charge once Catherine got
in charge Catherine formed real change
she formed the Revolt she formed the the
overthrow of fedra so this is the reason
why the people are behind her because
she actually put those words and put
power to the people and they actually
got fed out of there so they're gone so
this is the reason why the people are
following her and and believing in
anything that she says is because she's
the one that actually caused real change
and change what the oppressive nature
was from fedra to them having actual
control right now so I I yes liberated
them JD
um she she is she was that that that
emotional unemotional caring uncaring
individual that push change and she
pushed change in such a way that you had
a hardened uh soldiers following her one
thing I didn't like is in the end of
episode four they saw at the bottom of
the floor the floor was warping and he
knew what was down there and they didn't
handle that then and there
which led to what happened later and
that's what
that's the reason I just don't I'm not
vibing with her being the leader there
like because in that instant we got to
ride with her anymore huh no not really
but in that incidence she he was like yo
this is a series we gotta deal with this
and what did she say we'll deal with
this later and then you know we don't
really know because at that time we
never seen one of those do what it did
you know what I'm saying uh so we didn't
know what kind of damage that could do
uh the fact that they've seen it the
fact that they seen it and they were so
concerned when they saw it they knew
what they was what that was about they
knew what could happen with that and to
me that's why
I just find it if they would have had
people there that was saying yo I think
you're you you're more cared about your
brother's Revenge than you care about
our safety our needs us as a group then
if I would have seen a little bit of
back and forth with the actual people
and her I would say that that's more
realistic but to me they were riding for
this chick no matter what she did then
she could say yo go over there jump off
that cliff and try to grab us an apple
that's on that tree in the middle it's
like you're gonna do it yeah to me I I
just I didn't see it man she was
heartless she was heartless in a way
when she had the room full of snitches
shout out to the stitches shout out to
the Gunnies that's out there she had a
whole room full of Gunnies and it was
sitting there one little Gunner sat
there and was like yeah
um Henry is loose and uh and he's being
held up in a little hidey hole downtown
yeah that's how they caught the doctor
that's when she off the doctor and she
killed everybody in that room snitches
this was the best episode for stop
snitching you saw this episode this was
the best episode for stop snitching if
you are snitching please watch this
episode and change your ways before
Catherine runs down on you and puts you
under she gonna find you man she gonna
find you she's gonna throw in your life
nah yo the best scene in this jump
was when Henry talking to Joe and said
yeah man I'm a collaborator he said yo I
don't rep no snitches
did you like how Henry was actually if
you're going to do it today
you ripping a snitch
I said if that wasn't the best I'm the
only guy you got and I'm a snitch
it's like what you gonna do what you
gonna do nothing you gonna do exactly
what I tell you to do you gonna ride
with me cause I'm gonna get you out of
here I'm a snitch and I got the key
that was absolute dope dope Miss because
it was like what you going through I'm a
snitch that's it and I'm telling you to
your face I don't rep no snitches even
in a post-apocalyptic world
snitches ain't got no lames see
told you gunny face
[Laughter]
you know speaking of Henry you know I I
actually I want to talk a little bit
about Henry uh do you think that he did
a really good job at portraying Henry as
a character yeah
yeah
yeah I agree I think that he was
actually one of the highlights of the
whole episode was was Henry was able to
you know really give you a vivid opinion
on them without taking too much of you
know what he actually has done in the
world because you could tell he's he's
got his own demons and you could tell
that Henry has been out there he's he's
been he's been fighting these streets
and he's just tired and you know what I
like is just the realism of him he's
like yo I need your help he's like why
can't you do he's like dude I can't
fight I know I can't fight I don't go in
this situation for me to fight you know
what I do I snitch and if I can't snitch
you know what I do I team up people that
I know their way around the town so they
have to fight for me
yeah like
he said I saw you I saw what you did
like I saw how he was able to handle
yourself anytime and if this is the
reason why he's such a good actor
um anytime he heard a gunshot
anytime you saw a commotion
he flinched
he jumped
and when they were in a precarious
moment
when they was getting shot at
his first I thought was to run
not not to fight so you know at that
point he wasn't a fighter but he was
smart enough to know that Joel you know
had uh nerves of stale and Joe in in a
situation where his fight or flight to
kick in and he'll run Joe was a fighter
and him putting his his
confidence behind Joe's ability Joel
ability
was smart how how did you feel about
them making Sam deaf
it worked to the narration of I did I
did too I didn't have an issue with that
well I felt like you know that gave it a
little bit more the only thing I didn't
like is at the beginning
Sam stepped on glass and he acted like
he didn't know what glass made noise
it's like dude you in a post-apocalypse
world and you've been everywhere there's
no way you've never done glass the
entire time you've been in this
post-apocalypse world but he didn't hear
so do you think do you get it from like
he was asking Henry if it made noise or
who's asking her he didn't make noise
like because to me it kind of seemed
like he was asking is stepping on glass
gonna make noise you know what I'm
saying what I got from it it was it was
it loud noise oh okay okay I can see how
I can see how you can get that yeah
because he was just like you know like
yeah it makes noise like follow you know
how we do and you know not mimicking
sign language I don't know sign language
at all
to act like I do
um and they navigated through it you
know it was he just kept imparting
the world he was always conscious that
he couldn't hear and he always took the
time out to tell him what was going on
yeah especially when they're talking
about how to get out of the city like he
tapped on this he's like how we getting
out and he put it on his thing he's like
tunnels likes yeah because he knew oh
hold on we got Hollywood rules with the
five dollar Super Chat thank you so much
Hollywood came we got this glad to see
you back brother attic you keep up the
great work thank you thank you
appreciate it man great work thank you
yes
um yes of course I wasn't missing today
I was just overworked completely
overworked on Sunday and I truly missed
a great episode I definitely wanted to
sit down with the community I had some
good comedian jokes too man yeah one
thing you guys you ain't gonna want to
miss this weekend
make sure that you're there this week a
little bit early
um
trust me or you're gonna have to just go
back and watch the episode from the very
they won't have to uh we we have
precautions in place for people that
can't see it so
all right well you know I want to talk a
little bit about
the
the ending now let's go into the spoiler
uh spoiler territory right here so all
right you guys seen the episode you got
the spoiler room the red everywhere man
there's no way you can't see the
difference in the temperature in the
room right now it's hot in here man I'm
sitting here if I had a fan I'm oh my
God it's hot in here that means if you
can't take the heat walk out the door
the door's in the back man go go all
right so how did you feel about
the okay this is the part of the movie
the part of the show first off I still
don't like how they're staying away from
violence they're still doing it when it
came to the sniper I felt like the
sniping scene was worse because it there
wasn't a lot of pushback the snipers
sitting there up at the top sniping down
he sees Joe running to the right and he
doesn't have a mindset to be like yo
he's trying to stick up behind me you
know what I say he's continuing shooting
at nothing at that point because like
they're hiding behind the car they said
they weren't gonna move which they could
have moved we don't know it's off screen
but to me you you saw the person go out
of your your your your line of sight
obviously he has one goal and one goal
and only to sneak up behind you gotta
find out super trap from Hollywood Rose
King oh no okay yeah
I don't know okay okay sorry so what
what is your mindset on that like do you
do you want to hold that against the
show any
no they wanted to reenact the scene from
the video game inside the video but even
the video game when you popped in there
he wasn't at the window like that he was
prepared to attack Joel the moment he
walked in and to me they made that
person an idiot you know what I'm saying
like sure maybe the person that they put
out there they should have put out there
because he was an idiot like you you see
the dude leave you should have been
ready to give him that smoke but you
know I get where you're coming from I
mean I wasn't too hung up on it they
could have been you know distracting him
down there at the bottom we do that a
lot in fortnite you know I have uh we
just did it right now you know we have
people uh distracted and nine times out
of ten when you aiming down the scope
you don't get a chance to see who moved
out of your peripheral and it's night
time so but he was attempting to shoot
the whole time he was running he was
following him with the barrel so I mean
I I get I I guess we don't really have
to Ling on that too much if you don't
want to because there's not a whole lot
of explanation for that if they would
have had more into that Scene It would
have took away from the actual good part
of the episode so I I'm okay with that
but I do feel like it should have been a
little bit more realistic and you know
that's one of the parts that them going
away from the game was a little annoying
but it wasn't enough for them to sit
there and like stab him with a little
knife over and over again you know I
think he should do it better but it is
what it is it's not like the end of the
world now this next part is where I
honestly feel like
okay so I'm gonna I'm gonna have to read
uh JD uh she gave orders for him to hold
and they were on the way but JD when
those orders came through he was dead
already
yeah
so and not to mention you you get orders
to hold hold that position don't sit
there like an idiot getting about to get
stomped on I'm like I don't know I mean
in old houses too because I have an old
house anytime you walk up steps they
Creak and it's late night there's nobody
else outside you're the only person
making noise you're gonna hear those
steps Creek and if I hear you creaking
up my steps best believe by the time you
reach the top you're gonna go right back
down the bottom yeah I would have just
like like him trying to get beside the
door comes in got a big barrel it's not
going to be easy close range like that
Joe had the upper hand in the in the
first place but to me once again the
reason they didn't do that is because it
would have been harder to kill him off
camera if they had a close-up fight like
that and to me doing decisions like that
to make it less violent is hurting the
show overall
well I feel you there but there was a
lot of violence in this episode yeah
yeah but okay so let's let's get to that
this is one of the times in the show
where I think it played better in the
show than the game because you're able
to do more you couldn't have okay so
pretty much what happens is uh Joe shoot
Joe picks up the sniper just like he did
in the game uh shoots a style it shoots
a driver that pretty much has like a
giant trash uh trash trash truck that is
it has been real uh redesigned to pretty
much be a bulldozer so he shoots the
driver driver goes in that in in the
house
blows up so you think okay it's it's
something gonna happen you know well
yeah something definitely happens so
when we talked about earlier like the
giant sucking hole apparently
coincidentally there is one of those
under that house and the truck went
under it it explode when it exploded it
busted the top off and then there must
have been three or 400 clickers that
came out of that thing like it this is
one of the times where I feel like it it
did it was better in this like you know
in the in the game Joe just sat up there
and sniped like a couple dozen that got
close to them maybe not even a couple
dozen that's probably exaggerating but
ten maybe five ten in in the in the show
it's hundreds like it's so many that
homegirl brought the whole town to kill
two people it had him in the whole town
it was so much it was it was it was at
least it was all the Gunners it was it
was at least uh 30 of her good men and
them clickers make quick work of them
um this guy asked him when they asked
when Henry asked him you know you came
across two clickers and you're still
alive no no you're the right guy
you are the right guy so he understands
and everybody there understood how
dangerous they were let's talk about
that kid clicker though
yeah that was that that's one of the
things that you don't you don't want
violence like usually when it comes to
kids they leave them out like they don't
they don't kill them they don't turn
them into there's been very few times I
remember Walking Dead episode one
Interview with a Vampire yeah well
Walking Dead episode one we saw uh the
the little girl van uh zombie remember
like most of the time they stay away
from little kids and in general but man
this chick this little girl was crazy
following because because there's a time
where first off
it's
the amount of smoke that's going on in
the show and somehow Ellie has not been
killed like well I get it Joe's up there
protecting her but the amount of
clickers in this scenario you can't
protect them from that amount I think
that's why they added so many regular
soldiers to divide the attention
what I liked about this
you saw Joe
actually panicking
because it generally shocked him he's
probably never seen that many clickers
in one place I don't think it was that
um I will maybe maybe that's your
assessment of it right so your
assessment is is probably right on your
part my assessment of it is and and
enough and I'm watching it
Joe never let anybody get close to his
heart after Sarah died
after Sarah died he pretty much you know
uh went into mourning
uh his kid
and and very much a recluse
uh especially with his heart and he he
only let trust in but so far
Mount he has been tasked with watching
the kid and even Henry you know told him
you know your father
I can tell in your eyes because Joe told
him he said you know I'm sorry that I
came at you that way you know and uh you
know you got a kid and
you know you just probably did what you
felt that you had to do because Joe
probably played the scenario over in his
head a couple of thousand times
and now that he's in charge of this
child because you know when Henry said
uh yo you know your dad is crazy that's
not my dad they both you know I'm not
her father
but during that scene
where he was he was definitely panicked
when the gun jammed and she was about to
be mowed down by the that big truck
and you saw it in his eyes and I mean
I'm telling you man Pascal is playing
one hell of a Joe uh because the emotion
is coming through where he is fighting
for this kid and and I see the
connection starting to build as far as
what he would do for Ellie
but it has to get to the ultimate part
but we know in a video game it has to
when he makes certain decisions he has
to have that parental feeling over this
kid he has to feel like this is his
child so I'm seeing it starting to form
now and
he's giving so much to the character and
that you know I'm starting to see the
connection and I thought it was a good
thing especially in this whole episode
it was silent connections being made
throughout every scene and they're
growing closer as the Ellie and Joe that
we know from the game
yeah I feel like this episode's one of
the the times where you know they showed
violence with his clickers you know a
lot of people have an issue of like how
Sony did God of War they took out like
the human on human violence yeah you
know for the most part you never kill
humans in any of the new God of Wars and
so I think you're seeing more of that
here where it's like we're okay with
clickers doing stuff you know when they
killed the the big dude uh let me put
him on the background when they killed
this dude no not her when they killed
this dude like oh when he snatched it
panned out like so far much you couldn't
even really see it at it at that point
and like I get it you know they're
trying to appeal to a wider audience I
understand that but to me there's better
ways to incorporate violence that's more
tolerable than this like I feel like
they went all the way to the left side
because once again
if you really sit down and think about
it Joe's killed two people in this
entire show
yeah
and it's supposed to be apocalyptic
world and there's a lot of times in the
show I just don't feel like it is but
this was
this part was better because I felt like
the infected was an issue like you know
it wasn't necessarily the humans it was
it was the infected and they came in
huge hordes well Joe didn't get a chance
to kill any humans any any people that
he did to well he did Kill the one uh
the two
well he killed a couple of people the
guy with the sniper
he killed him and he killed the woman
that was behind the wheel that was
driving the truck yeah so he's up to
four I forgot about him he's only four
people but
most of the kills were you know clickers
you know infected so to disassociate
yourself with that level of violence on
people
I think Sony is probably taking a stance
that they don't want to
look like they are a glorifying uh human
non-human violence if if if that makes
any sense but I know we come from the
pedigree of the game where in the
majority of the antagonists is uh humans
and we have to you know take out a lot
of humans along the way in this in in
the game so you know the the show
is a departure from what we're used to
and sometimes it's uh a little jarring
in us getting that experience that we
want from the game so I get it you know
it's like um you know we're still in
spoilers seeing uh gas lightning said I
mean Gabby's probably going to bash uh
Joe's head in scenes into they're
probably gonna pan them off screen like
at this point why would they not like
you know you you you see the commotion
go but instead like in the game you saw
the whole thing but I feel like they're
gonna do like that kind of like they did
with the sniper on here where she's
gonna swing up gonna pan off and you're
just gonna hear him screaming or
something like no I know what they're
gonna do they're gonna make uh
Ellie watch and you're going to be
watching the horror through Ellie's eyes
as you know yeah that's probably that's
probably you'll probably see the the
golf club or if what if they choose to
use a golf club you'll see it go up and
down in her eyes like her actual eyes
yeah so I mean I think it's a good show
I think this is a good episode uh you
know uh what would be one of the best
ones yeah I would say the only one
that's even remotely this good is the
first episode well I was a fan of the
three
um of because what three encapsulated
and what it did and was the story it
told because I really uh understood bill
now
um and you know Bill and Frank's story
so and that's not a popular opinion with
a lot of people or some people do side
with me it's it's wherever you find
Fallen according to spoiler screen by
the way yeah okay but um one and two
definitely uh you know high water marks
this one has to be a five this one has
to be a five popcorn for the simple fact
that they showed urgency they showed
stealth they showed stuff in the game
that was in this episode and I'm talking
about scene break down the scene
breakdown
um that town when I iconic pieces iconic
set pieces and then you got a chance to
see what a horde of clickers does to uh
militia now not all militia was military
trained shout out to Sir duck
um not all of them was um military
trained but some of them was and the one
that was highly military trained got his
head ripped off his shoulders so once
the general went down everybody else
went down to be honest with you but
again to be honest with you there's
Kathy do you notice the uh the bloater
got away
yeah but he leads the pack and he went
right back to the town like so yeah
they're all dead down too by the time
they get to the town they're going to
overrun that town
because they left their defense they
couldn't they couldn't what I didn't
like
we did we never touched on you know uh
Sam being affected and Sam attacking
Ellie um but we're all for spoilers so
watch it that you will
we we never you know talked about
if
Henry never gave up Michael
they still be under
uh Federal uh occupation
still be there
Sam would be dead
because the outcome that Henry was
trying to avoid was Sam being dead but
Sam died at Henry's hands
how disturbing that must have been to
Henry because he had no other option at
that point in time but to do what he did
it was just it was a real emotional
roller coaster and I'm watching it
through uh with with my wife watching
her
uh react to what's happening on screen
and it's crazy to see somebody that has
nothing to do with the video game absorb
this world and the manner that she is
and it's it's it's like a fun trip to be
honest with you to see how she's dealing
with it and it's crazy
I feel you uh that that's where I'm off
on that it's like I said
that's why I didn't like her as a leader
because she led them into that situation
yeah especially sending that many people
to kill like potentially two people
yeah for two people but yeah it is what
it is but you know I think you know as
far as it is uh that's pretty much all
for the last of a show we have for this
week you know we'll definitely cover you
know Last of Us Part uh most likely
unless this next episode's really good
we're gonna cover six and seven together
because next week Ant-Man and we we're
going to have a special guest on that
show uh when we talk about Ant-Man I'm
going to uh hit him up this week because
I told him to watch it uh so I'm
definitely gonna send a bad signal out
to him because I I do want his opinion
on this and I definitely want him here
so we're gonna um welcome him into the
realm uh to talk about this movie with
us and get his opinion on it but also
anybody that subscribed to the you said
the 799 is here and the patreon yeah and
I'm ending the video for The Last of Us
Part Two all right so uh make sure that
you you uh get into that patreon to send
your questions in and remember those
questions go on any of the shows that we
do have the attic show uh iron Lords
podcast and r r with the Lord's uh
combat talk with kick ain't really a
thing but uh please definitely uh check
that out and give us these questions so
we have these questions when we see
Ant-Man this week
you know I'm putting the patreon in the
chat so like I said you guys go there um
you know we have uh the five dollar tier
you can ask any question any of the
shows IOP addicts show
um you know r r with the Lords and
combat talk when uh there's there's
fights for a king to do and uh you know
seven dollars till you can see the
reactions you know react to anime right
now you know we're not just gonna only
react to anime if you want us to watch
something unique you know you can always
request that in the ten dollar tier
which you know is to request us to react
to certain things you know if we get
that tier gets too out of control we'll
probably make it a poll thing where if
you know we'll put four of the the
options that's in there and we'll let
the whole uh patreon members uh thing
vote you know I want to appreciate
everyone for coming on uh we had a
pretty solid show you know uh Once Again
Last of Us took the took the the ball
out we usually talk about that the most
uh but I I appreciate it for coming
through man hit that like button on your
way out don't forget your shoes because
I don't need shoes I got plenty of shoes
so get them shoes and hit that like
button when you leave the door but you
better shut the door don't leave that
[__] open
close the door please it's a draft in
here I see y'all next week guys hey
Ant-Man this week if you don't see it
don't worry about it because we're going
to tell you when to get out of the uh
yeah I I will write the show and uh you
know we'll talk a good amount at the
beginning non-spoiler and then we'll go
into the spoiler tech toy but until next
week when we do the spoiler Castle
Ant-Man it's peace enjoy your